[Music]
hey this town's buzzing Academy Award
nominations are out
that's exciting sounds like you guys got
something that's fantastic I just
warning the Academy only nominated the
Zips to me only nominated nine films for
Best Picture instead of ten yeah so
apparently the Academy didn't see a
Madea Christmas Oprah Winfrey was this
is the big story today Oprah Winfrey was
shut out did you hear about this Oprah's
movie the butler was not nominated for
Best Picture yeah
Oprah is said to be very disappointed
but she's being comforted by her 700
real Butler's rubbing her feet the movie
gravity received 10 nominations yeah
yeah it's the film where Sandra Bullock
achieves what every Hollywood actress
dreams of true weightlessness
good enough let's talk about it Justin
Bieber's egg throwing scandal continues
to rock are you booing the concept
Bieber or just eggs you don't like eggs
eggs really wow that's an interesting
choice no I really don't want your
answer no this thing his egg throwing
scandal is rocking the judicial world
yes police seized Justin Bieber's cell
phone and sources say the singer is
worried they'll find nude selfies on it
yeah Bieber said it's not fair I've
worked really hard to keep my gender a
secret
I'm totally never taken a nude selfie
even I don't want to see what's going on
there legal experts say if Justin Bieber
is convicted of a felony he could be
deported back to Canada American
officials are hopeful they can get
deported changed to catapulted I'm just
love to see that happen
chris Christie busy dealing with his
bridge scandal chris Christie has
responded to the bridge scandal crisis
by hiring the legal team of Gibson Dunn
and Crutcher yeah they'll assist the
team Christie typically works with Ben
and Jerry
he's a heavy man a prominent gay
conservative says he's leaving the
Republican Party because he now believes
it is intolerant yeah friends described
the gay conservative as slow to notice
things country country music star Trace
Adkins was on a cruise ship he got in a
brawl with a Trace Adkins impersonator
nobody's exactly sure who won thank you
a new study shows that heavy drinking
can speed up memory loss in middle-aged
men yeah none of that but a new study
shows that heavy drinking can speed up
memory loss in middle-aged men
[Applause]
an alcoholic